these images show the projection of
power a few of the dozens of offshore
outposts and military bases china has
built in recent years
ownership of these islands reefs and
built up sandbanks in the south china
sea and east china sea is disputed
several states claim the islands for
their rich fishing grounds possible oil
deposits and strategic locations
there have been showdowns vietnam says
this is one of its boats being rammed by
a chinese vessel on the open sea
and filipinos have protested a chinese
law authorizing its coast guard to
destroy other country structures on
islands it claims
just a few reasons why one of china's
indo-pacific neighbors decided it needs
to act
last week australia sealed a deal to
build nuclear-powered submarines with
state-of-the-art u.s and british
technology
and so friends orcas is born
a new enhanced trilateral security
partnership between australia the united
kingdom and the united states
china responded immediately and sternly
australia is solely responsible for the
difficult situation of current chinese
australian relations
australia must correctly recognize the
reasons for setbacks in the two
countries ties and think carefully
whether to treat china as a partner or a
threat
other reactions were mixed
strengthening defense cooperation
between the u.s britain and australia is
important for peace in the indo-pacific
we hope the decision
won't
disturb
the situation in the region
but given the region's disputes and
military buildups
more disturbances seem practically
assured
lots to unpack here let's bring in
garema mohan a fellow at the german
marshall fund of the united states with
a research focus on the indo-pacific
karima welcome let's just talk about
friday's quad leaders meeting first now
the leaders of the united states japan
australia and india are meeting in the
backdrop of last week's orcas security
pact what can we expect from this court
meeting
so while the orcas is primarily a
security pack the quad has a much
broader remit so i think we have to see
the orcas and quad as complementary and
not competitive initiatives from the
meeting on friday we can see
i'm sure we'll certainly see a few
announcements around the three working
groups that were created in the last
meeting around vaccines where the quad
is on track to deliver one billion doses
to the indo-pacific by next year on
critical technologies on climate change
we'll certainly see a new initiative
perhaps around regional connectivity and
infrastructure to offer an alternative
to china's bri
and we will see
an announcement around maritime security
cooperation so a really broad remit for
the quad leaders summit this time but
you also mentioned that there were
complementary initiatives the court
dialogue and the orcas security fact
another thing that is common to them of
course is that they both essentially
counter chinese influence in the
indo-pacific even though the leaders
don't explicitly name china and this is
in addition to existing security packs
such as those between the united states
and japan as i wonder therefore if all
this alliance building against china if
this is a good thing for the
indo-pacific so let me start by saying
that it is china's assertive behavior
particularly vis-a-vis the quad
countries that has created the
conditions for these four partners to
work together in different permutations
and combinations there is really a
networked security architecture emerging
in the indo-pacific but i have to say
that the quad particularly under the
biden administration is not just an
anti-china security alliance first of
all it is not even an alliance but under
the biden administration in its
particular iteration it has become much
broader it argues that it wants to
provide solutions to regional problems
public goods and therefore it is a more
positive thing
as i mentioned the quad leaders summit
this one and also the previous one
focused really on bigger problems like
covet
climate change technology it's also a
recognition of the fact that the
challenge from china is not just in the
security realm it is actually much
broader and it exists extends to trade
technology
political influence infrastructure and
therefore the four countries are coming
together in various coalitions to
provide alternatives and solutions for
that in the indo-pacific that might be
the wider remit potentially with quad in
particular but then i wonder how china
views this given particularly the
statements that have been coming out
from china in which the term
cold war mentality keeps getting
repeated in terms of the quad and the
orcas so how do you view the chinese
response and how do you see this
expanding moving forward
well china's response is of course
expected it is always displeasure one
has to note that china works in
coalitions of its own so it's not just
these four countries that are working in
these coalitions china is also working
in different combinations interestingly
there's also russia-india-china
trilateral so there are opportunities
for dialogue and positive collaboration
if countries are so interested but i
have to bring up the recent example of
the german frigate buy-in which uh
requested a port call with china and
that was rejected now for your a lot of
european countries that are taking a
more inclusive uh view of the
indo-pacific which is more focused on
cooperation and less on competition
china by rejecting this port call sent a
very clear signal
that even inclusivity in this really
mild form is not acceptable
and therefore the chinese behavior
particularly increasing assertiveness
vis-a-vis europe as well does not create
the conditions necessary for
the cooperation that it says that it
seeks
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us today
garema mohan from the german marshall
fund of the united states